i love this man and i'm not saying it
because he's on hold maybe even hearing
my introduction
but i do you know i love talking about
him here and i love pounding this table
about what he is doing
because i've seen it from the beginning
i've seen it from the beginning and now
he is the eddie robinson award winner
for the fcs coach of the year also the
swac coach of the year he is coach of
jackson state football dion sanders here
on the rich eyes and show mercedes-benz
vance phone line how are you coach prime
how you doing man you could call me cody
cody
i thought you were the comeback player
of the year you still are right dion i
was
the hair is back but i'm cody now
cody
you were the first guy
that was promoting the podcast
for the record oh dion oh you have no
idea prime the stories that i've been
telling from this chair i know you're a
busy man so i know you're probably not
keeping track of everything um but uh i
told the story the other day did you see
kurt warner's shiny jacket oh my god i
saw it
i did i actually liked it i liked it
[Music]
okay
because the rest of the country was just
he trended off of his choice of jacks
because it wasn't kurt like you know but
you know if mike would award or someone
else with water he would get away with
it but it wasn't kirk like that's right
he definitely it was it was something we
weren't seeing coming so i told the
story here where everyone's talking
about did you ever wear something that
you thought looked good but then a bunch
of other people didn't i told the story
of when you took me fedora shopping in
chicago do you remember that dionne yeah
i loved it i removed it you remember
that and you you said
that's where that and you and i you
you've
i thought i looked good in it dionne
right
you look great in that
and it was timely it was it was time
it's because it's cold right it's
practical it was crazy it was freezing
oh my gosh
i remember that oh my gosh i just
remember all those days with us and i
cannot oh my god right we had to we had
some heck of a days man you you remember
the flight
um that we took late night there was
some little plane and marshall like just
came out of nowhere and said yeah we get
ready to take this we are a marshall
place i was like come on oh like come on
dude come on man
it was from green bay
yes to oakland okay
it was from green bay to oakland
and we had to stop off in the middle of
the country in the middle of the night
to regas
schefter was kicked shifter was kicked
off the plane because we were overweight
and he took the he took the lights with
him commercial flight
to oakland it was horrible man it was a
horrible night and that's though when he
was up he was nervous about going to
oakland because he had just reported
that uh art shell was going to be fired
by the end of the season you remember
the raiders called him a false rumor
mongerer
and then a mugger
a mongrel a mongrel you used to kill him
with that
well you're the one we were in the car
in front of him he drove a separate car
because he's going to the airport after
the pregame show and you're the one who
told the security guard to stop him to
say no monger is allowed
[Laughter]
we had some heck of a times man
i thought i thought of so many things
that that was unbelievable man oh it was
great and now prime i could not be more
uh excited for you because i also all of
us when we were going through all that
had a front row seat
about you
and coaching and coaching your youth
coaching the kids creating your own
school to make sure that you were
coaching the kids in the manner in which
you wanted to coach them i saw it i saw
it and i knew how serious you were about
it and to see you
win the eddie robinson award just hits
me right where it should in all the
fields i wonder what about you prime
that you have an eddie robinson award
winner [ __ ] you have no idea i'm
thankful i'm elated i'm happy
i'm uh appreciative because my staff was
wonderful that supported me and when i
went down with you know where my
mess and then my illnesses and my my
foot
they supported me and they had my back
and they kept the torch burning
it was a wonderful thing and just so to
understand that journey from once i
first started man and
to be coming in there whenever i could
and late sometimes because i was
coaching and i wouldn't even come over
there because i was coaching you know in
the hall of fame
i loved it just that much and to just
see
the toil be recognized for such a
prestigious award as eddie robinson like
man you got to be kidding me eddie
robinson
so it's a blessing man and i'm truly
appreciative
and so how are you feeling
you're good right now
i i worked out this morning i'm doing
maria i'm still like 25 pounds down i
got to gain back i got to give my weight
back uh but i'm getting stronger my man
i'm getting stronger
every day and i'm lifting i'm working
i'm just trying to get it back i love it
and then
hopefully i'll be
walking soon okay and i i look forward
to hearing about all that and seeing all
that and watching you
um you know stalking the sidelines as a
coach should so i'll ask you a question
here deion sanders that i would have
asked you if you were sitting next to me
on on nfl network um about
uh you and travis hunter and getting the
top recruit and all the land to come to
you to jackson state and your staff
getting him to come to you to jackson
state
why do you think
people were so surprised about that
dion
that you got uh
people are always astonished for what
they hadn't seen
and they hadn't seen a
a young man
of that caliph caliber go to a
hbcu
in the last 30 years
so
that's why they were surprised then the
idiots start to think foul play how we
gonna play foul we we don't have any
funding if we had funding now you could
play the game like everyone else plays
but we don't have that so you can't play
that game
i gave you a nugget within that last
comment by the way
oh i saw him
travis
is a kid who studied me like crazy and
people don't understand this kid really
really studied me i mean to the point
where
this kid is a he adores fishing like
when i found that out like okay
okay you're a kid from the inner city
but you love the fish and you love the
bass fish so where are you going to bass
fish you know in the inner city so
things like that it was just a synergy
and you got to understand i'm 54.
and if travis is 18 just say for
instance his mother had him when she was
20 or 18 she's 36 or she's 38. that was
kind of in my era what i was really
rolling
you know what i mean
so
she she would have uh understood exactly
who
i was back then on the field and who i
am right now
to
prayerfully take her son
from uh being a young man a young man to
a fully grown man that's responsible
and i don't like you know when i talk to
parents i tell them the truth i'm not
promised your son any number i'm not
promising he's going to start i'm not
promised him a nil deal i'm promising
you he's gonna come here he's gonna get
a good education he's gonna work his
butt off and earn every darn thing he
gets that's all i promise
that's it
i'm a straight shooter you know that oh
i do know that and you also told me once
upon a time that you didn't see a grown
man shave till you got to college you
told me that exactly exactly and then
that never so uh heard of a bank account
until i got to college
i'm sorry so i got the pros
i got into the pros so i a lot of things
i didn't understand
so now i'm implementing those things
that would have uh
blessed me truly if i had known in
college
a lot of things that i'm implementing
with my team
that if i had known that in college i
would be not just a better man but i'd
probably be uh
in a better place financially not that
i'm not but i would be in a better place
financially
and i would have more wisdom
tremendously
so your pitch to the kid does not
include nil
at all
because um i mean
we can't guarantee that we can't promise
you that i don't have those type of uh
contacts like hey man i'm gonna get you
this nil deal that don't that don't come
along with me
what comes along with me is if you ball
not if i never say if when you ball when
you do what you need to do and you show
that type of promise and you clean up
the whole external um makeup of yourself
and you just clean up your whole gang
i'm pretty sure endorsers will want to
partner with you
but tell me something man
and you i might be crazy
why would a company want a kid out of
high school
like what
what do you what the heck do you have to
offer america
that's what i don't get so some of these
colleges that's reporting some of these
kids get millions of dollars out of high
school i don't see it
i can see if the kid has already
done something in college
and establish himself or herself in
college
and have the likability and or
endorsability but
right out of high school i don't see it
don't see it
wish i did but i don't see it
because i don't know the kid if i'm a
sponsor i don't know what you're capable
of doing i don't know
how you're going to handle the spotlight
and that's a scary place if i'm a
company
deion sanders here on the rich eisen
show
jackson state
head coach eddie robinson award winner
for fcs coach of the year uh here the
day before christmas so what's what's
the plan what do you what do you see
jackson state football looking like
right now two three years from now
like what we recruited up i i don't look
three two three years from now rich i
take care of president yep because if i
don't miss the moment so we recruited up
at every position that we needed to
recruit up at uh
and we had some guys that weren't
eligible last year that were better than
the guys that were on the field this
past season
and i can't wait for america to see them
we recruited some guys
grad tran i have 40 40 20 rich that's my
formula 40 grad transfers 40 in the
portal 20 high school
and
what we recruited
is phenomenal we recruited up at every
position that we needed helping
so i look for a better team i look for a
team that's smarter
tougher
a little faster a lot more physical
although we led the nation in sacks
and uh amongst the where the top and uh
fcs and defense
but we gotta get the offensive line
together
and get uh get that offense going and
i'm addressing that right now well i
think you know
i guess let me be more fine point on it
well i mean because scheduling is also
so important in college football and you
know like who do you like do you intend
to go and knock on the doors or or
basically
want to go play some big time if you
will blue blood college football
programs certainly i mean you're
stationed right there in the the sec
country i mean is that is that the goal
where you just want to you know as you
say that's
that's not the goal right now the goal
is to dominate where you are not win but
to dominate where you are then you look
forward
down the line to scheduling some of
those games right now those games are
financially beat down that's what i call
them and that's what some hbcus choose
to do i'm going to go
to
these various schools and i'm going to
get my butt kicked but i'm going to walk
out of there with 750 000 million
dollars that's not worth it to me that's
to me that's the ultimate sellout to
children
so i'm going to pay i know i'm not going
to win but you're going to kick my butt
i'm going to lose three to four players
to injury and you're going to humiliate
my team i'm going to have to build them
back up next week to play again
yeah that that doesn't make any sense to
me
like if if i know i have a team rich
that the interior line
defensively and offensively as well as a
nice rotation and substitution can can
withstand that i'll do it because i know
the skill positions they're already
suitable they can do it but the where
the difference lies is the
offense and defensive lines that's where
there's a difference
well and then you'll you'll you already
know where the next one is going to go
because you you must get it all the time
anyway so i'll just jump in because the
idea is that if you can't get that at
jackson state then you'll go someplace
where you can get it
where do what are you i don't i don't
honestly my man i'm not even you know i
don't like to yeah i cried to you for a
lot to you i i don't i'm not looking
to tomorrow i don't do that right now
because i promise you i really i focus
on today i focus on the now i focus on
maximizing the moment and giving these
kids all i have today now when tomorrow
comes i concern myself about that
tomorrow but i don't i don't look down
there that's why we've been so
successful we really focus and dominate
today and in the moment i i know i've
had a front row seat to all that dionne
i'm just you know i'm going i'm going
with places where people i'm sure are
already asking you that yeah yeah
you know their question where when i
what's the build up what's the exit plan
what's this was that i i don't think
like that man i i got to rich not only
do i have to win i have to dominate like
i i
i take this
this this next phase of my life just
like i did the game when i played the
game i got to dominate this thing
and we're winning but we're not
dominating
and that's the plan over 2022 and beyond
so uh last one for you on this subject
matter prime um is uh i'll i'll give you
the opportunity you you take it or not
um the fact that you took travis hunter
from florida state what does that mean
does it mean something
i think uh
i don't think he never belonged to them
i don't think i took him i don't think
he ever belonged to them okay um
and i saw the burning of the jerseys in
the case i saw all the foolishness i
left my butt off first of all
but
this is something i don't understand and
i wasn't gonna say this rich but you're
my guy so i gotta say it on your show
okay i think it was either a year before
or a year before that
is that uh
their head coach which who i'm very fond
of who i think is a great coach who i
think is gonna do tremendous
um feats for our my alma mater call me
to help him recruit
a kid out of louisiana
and i facetime the kid i facetimed the
mother
and i did my thing
florida state has been using me for
years
to do what i do to help influence these
kids to come to the wonderful alma mater
no problem
that did it i believe the kid signed
so what's the difference of me doing
that and doing it for myself
so it was good enough for you
but it's not good enough for me
that's what i have a problem with
so you're saying now
i'm good enough to get you players
but the player or i'm not good enough to
get me players which one is it are we
not good enough at jackson state or i'm
not good enough as a person
i would like that answer
i don't know if you're going to get that
answer dion but i know but it doesn't
make sense to you i mean i'm really dead
that
that's the thing
you know how long how many years florida
state has been selling me
and and
my accolades and what i've accomplished
to come to that wonderful prestigious
university which i'm proud of yeah yeah
so if i'm gonna sell me what i don't
sell me
you selling me
i can't sell me
mm-hmm
dion sanders
that's something to ponder yeah
that's something for christmas weekend
i'm stroking my beard
i'm stroking my beard you don't see me
stroking my beard um so uh last one for
you here um
i don't know how much pro ball you're
you're locked in on like back in the day
i know you're still doing stuff uh on
that front talking about it but what do
you think of uh that kid diggs
playing in dallas oh again the
cornerback uh
i think he's phenomenal man what do you
think of him i think he's phenomenal i
really hadn't had a chance to really
study and watch it right
i used to be into the pro game totally
now i'm into the college game
but the kid what he's accomplished
is
phenomenal
um
of course you know the next phase is is
going man the man gets the best every
week you know how that is yep you know
how that is then you then you start
really to get the accolades and the talk
of the guys that's been doing it for
years you know like a guy like patrick
peterson came out of the womb playing
man-to-man against the opponent's best
receiver um
jalen ramsey same way came out of the
womb his first year playing against the
best man-to-man and you're going to get
balls they're not going to throw away
from you because you're going to be on
the opponent's best that kid can play
the game man and i'm proud of him um
what he's doing out there on the field
four cornerbacks
i'm i'm proud of him yeah and parsons
too again i i know i'm i'm kind of
diamond man
we have a kid um
um that plays
defense in there was an inside
linebacker that we moved to defensive
end that um was all swag all fcs
everything james houston that came to us
from the university of florida
the kid was a
kid just bawled out this year
and got all kind of accurate but he
reminds me of that guy and my whole
pitch to him was look man
he parsons was the inside guy now he's
outside the inside he's everywhere you
can do the same because he was the
inside linebacker but he would have
started for us at inside so we moved him
to the rushing right my god
he broke records and he's phenomenal
parsons is a freak of nature that could
possibly he or digs could possibly
be the defensive mvp
arguably they could be the mvp depending
on how they finish up this season huh
and you know
where does this cowboys defense rank up
with yours what do you think
i don't i can't compare that i don't i
don't know how good they are
statistically i hadn't watched that i
don't know if they rank like that i
don't know if they're like that all
right well dick's gonna shut down dick's
gonna shut down irvin too then right is
that what you're saying
slow your roll
oh you wrote
hey hey that mike irving was a problem
man that mike irving was a problem
yeah he was a problem with that on that
field man believe me
yep and he's still he's gonna watch you
got rich i do watch you guys on sunday
mornings i'll watch you guys okay so
then you see we're still doing our thing
with mooch oh you're still killing it
man you still you know you know i owe
the muchi man a call i'm probably going
to call him today as well good
because we all talk about you all the
time prime we love you uh miss you and
rooting for you like uh like you can't
imagine although i'm maybe
i appreciate you man i missed the crew
the original crew with marshall and all
i i messed up
we talked about
still with you well deltufo is off today
because he's never here um so oh my god
he will be so upset that you gave him
that shout out um and he's not here too
bad you snooze you lose well your whole
your whole crew is uh
unbelievable i remember you know when
you decided to go off and put your pinky
extension on and put your pinky in there
and your feet in the sand i was able to
fill in for you
your crew is unbelievable man you have
unbelievable well we feel the same way
about you you got to interview you chad
you got morgan freeman here i mean you
chatted with morgan freeman on this set
back in the day yeah that that is great
that is that goes down to history yeah
that's something i definitely tell the
kids i love you my interview
right you know
prime um love you
you be well appreciate you thanks for
the call i miss you thanks for the call
lovely please tell susan all the kids
and the dogs i said
i appreciate you have a merry christmas
i will do that right back at you dion
that's uh dion sanders the coach of the
year coach of the year coach prime
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here